welcome to this video I'm playing raffle
highest on Raphael and from Armenia and
it's a it's a trump I really should ban
down the line against the Trump i keep
getting our positions that are not
comfortable at all ok against that i'm
going to go into player just like just
like a french defence i cannot be too
bad Oh might be five i-95 hmm i played
this too quickly and I'd be five was
good very good ok now might be five i
have e five this was my idea I wanted to
get this pin get this pin going
well i hope that dumb i get quick play
with p5p form here we go
okay I really I want to open up lines
here quickly of course Knight takes
bishop takes it takes spatter queen 85
Pusha basics hmm I to me it feels like
I'm pretty cook here yeah this is very
slow what he's doing the check should a
six
g5 9710 g6 maybe maybe if I we have this
check
checkin Knight e5 maybe I need to I need
to clear the C file this is some really
important okay check and now how to how
to do that Queen night a five-night see
form of course f6 is hanging but it sets
matter of matter of being quick here I
mean quit with the attack not quick with
with any moves still should i move the
night I probably should 97 yeah I cannot
really suck it yes
no it's not John Knight b6 probably
attending nights you form
check normally in this kind of position
you play king age eight now there should
i should do that yeah this is still
fairly safe it should be fired for
something I can just take h7 and knight
Knight to c4 is some substantial okay
it's just a check right
I thought night a5 p.m. and isn't this
strong or would be 80 be ADA is even
better intending Bishop e3 I just have
more pieces near the king this is why I
think black is fine here he basically
only has a check and like Rosanna yes
there's nothing against no Bishop e3 or
any Bishop move for that matter be to us
a b2 is gone my attack is just just
quicker maybe a kak ya now this is
already lost I've got two pieces near
the King too many pieces near the king
to be honest I think this is too slow
this is h4 h5 g5 he probably needs to do
something else nigeria or something i
actually already here think that black
is in great shape I'm cuca on the
queenside it's just like that all this
isn't isn't so effectively placed
alright thanks for watching